well everyone my word it is already time
for the third annual your viewers Awards
it seems like just yesterday that three
years ago we did the very first one if
you guys don't know what this is this is
a really special time of year for me and
for other YouTube movie reviewers out
there this is just a really cool time
for the YouTube movie reviewing
community to be able to express
themselves about how they felt about the
movies performances and various things
involving film that was in the previous
year various youtubers in the community
are contacted to vote for their favorite
films and performances of the year this
has already been done the nominees have
been tallied and if you want to see
those nominees and who are up for grabs
for certain Ward's you can go to Jeremy
Jahns channel you can go to the schmoes
know channel they got videos on both of
their channels right now detailing those
nominees now the schmoes masterminded
this show and they created it along with
Jeremy's help and everyone else has
helped to come in to kind of create this
great community show that we can show
you guys and have some fun some
entertainment value and also be able to
have a nice voice for the people you
know it's a way for the people to be
able to express like this is how i feel
about something and no this isn't the
People's Choice Awards where Johnny Depp
wins every single year even if he wasn't
in a movie it's not like that I was
pleasantly surprised by many nominees
that were chosen it's not predictable
you know a lot of people were like oh I
know exactly what's going to be it's
going to be this on that but actually it
was pretty surprising the choices that
were nominated this year and I think
they're really great so go check them
out one last announcement I'm actually
going to be traveling to LA this year to
be in the studio filming with them for
the show I'm gonna go on the schmoes
know podcast with the schmoes
jeremyjahns and my buddy John the flick
pick we're all going to go to LA and
we're going to be there for that podcast
it's Thursday eight to ten pm on the
toad hop network I'm going to put up
various links on my facebook if you
don't follow me it's facebook.com /
chris stuckmann you can follow me there
or at my twitter at chris underscore
Stuckmann i'm going to be putting up
those links when we go live on the
podcast we're going to be filming that
your viewers in LA it's going to be
really cool to meet some of my buddies
so I've been friends with for years
looking forward to guys i hope you are
as pumped for the your viewers awards as
i am it's coming to you soon more than
likely about a week before the Oscars
now one problem this does present is
that I
be in LA for broken city and mama I will
try to see those films while I'm in LA
the reviews make it up late I apologize
for that but that's going to be a side
effect of me going to LA this weekend I
really appreciate you watching and your
patience look forward to your viewers
Awards very soon thanks a lot for
watching guys and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck min
eyes